it's time now for our scene an unseen
segment where we expose the big cultural
stories of the day well tonight we break
down the optics of President Trump
versus Chuck and Nancy the rebuttal that
launched a thousand memes
and we do that with our own Raymond
Arroyo he'll caught uh was caught on
film
committing a crime you know there's no
way we're gonna to not be we have
surveillance video and joining us now
the Afra mentioned Raymond Arroyo okay
Raymond this thing last night we were
all sitting back there in the offices
and when they walked out Chuck and Nancy
after the president spoke the peals of
laughter now that's unfair exterior
everybody is a supermodel
that's fine why was that so compelling
well it was so compelling because
audiences watch it had a lot to do with
the staging it had a lot to do with what
the speaker's what Pelosi the President
and Schumer were doing intentionally or
unintentionally Laura on TV little
things matter people are looking for
visual clues to agree or disagree with
what his speakers saying now in this
case in the case of that rebuttal things
got a little creepy right off the top
from that wide holeshot that slow push
upon just directly to the american
people tonight about how we can end this
shutdown don't meet the needs that they
may notice notice how schumer is staring
into the camera with this menace and and
nancy never blinks as she speaks she's
kind of just robotically running through
it and the hallway push at the top that
was a big mistake look what's produced I
mean know when Obama when he did his big
first speech at the Democratic
convention listening they fly in
Spielberg producer Geffen that came in
that thing was she shot you know the
kids at Hofstra this reminded me of a
horror movie frankly that with the with
the slow push watching these two figures
at the end of a whole psych hour
what was that this is a movie called it
follows you want to go voter no but then
there was the moment Lord where Pelosi
finished her portion of the speech and
then she handed the baton to Schumer
watch this exchange tells us a lot in
the government thank you Peter Schumann
now look what she does with her jaw she
does this strange jaw readjustment
audiences look they were wondering why
am I kind of thrown off by this those
visuals send different cues they make
people a little frightened and then
Schumer he speaks to her he thanks her
without ever looking over to her he's
like thank you very much speaker Pelosi
let me tell you the border is in big
trouble
well either that again we've had the air
of Nosferatu about it staring in that
way that's what everybody I kept eating
for at this what did he look like though
it was like that one it's a super famous
Batman you two phases got one eye a
little I had to go we're gonna run out
it's not Ken let's go to the president
in the Oval Office now you and I saw
something more when we when we watch
this the president was in command he was
seated there but if you notice watch the
president his eyes are a little off
camera now how does that happen well
it's either the prompter is beneath the
lens which means you're looking down
rather than into the camera or the the
the something was off or the camera was
too close to him but whatever the reason
it's he's not looking through to the
viewer that's the one that's yeah but he
was but otherwise he was really in
command very emotive and I I thought
made it and it made something important
he was not he was kind of Reaganesque I
thought but it was a little off on the
camera shot but I shouldn't say that
whoever did that's now gonna get in
trouble well not trouble probably only
we notice that your TV now needless to
say key picky Chuck and Nancy Laura
captured the imagination of many on the
internet a slew of memes rose up almost
instantly all created by us no not true
here are three of my favorite so what we
found this one is the Green Acres me
having failed to get Mexico to pay it's
a great anchors theme behind them and
then there was this next meme I call it
the head swap theory this keeps me up at
night thinking at this they put Pelosi
space on one side and Schumer's on the
other and finally Nancy and Chuck at
supervillains oh my that awful so cruel
well I just kept thinking of Obama
saying that we need fresh blood in the
SS we got him all right you were at that
off-the-record
you want all the fancy PB invited they
invited anchors of different networks
but somebody broke someone clearly broke
the ground rules here and that hurts
everybody cuz now you're not gonna get
any incidents heading I would but the
New York Times said two people
briefed on the discussion shared this
information with the New York Times you
know what that means one of these
anchors ran back talked to their staff
they leaked to the New York Times that's
called laundering sources I don't need
to stop you right now because we
actually have some breaking or breaking
after frantic manhunt police are making
an arrest of a man accused of relieving
himself in a California family's yard
and still extension cords the suspect
are Arroyo hmm name rings a bell also
caught on camera getting intimate with
an intercom and that was in the middle
of the night and someone else's home
Raymond what do you not say for yourself
are you the doorbell licker
no I am the man was identified as
Roberto Daniel Arroyo I will have you
know he is no relation thank god this
poor guy he's a homeless man he's
logging off he's licking the doorbell of
this home they apparently did this for
three hours now I don't know about you
Laura but I've never looked anything for
three hours and if I do at the risk of
sounding like those ad commercials call
medical help other than stamps I'm not
gonna be licking anything for more than
three minutes muster less three hours
okay was not me I was not good maybe he
could go to a federal judge in the Ninth
Circuit and he could say I'm gonna Wed
this it was an employee could marry
could marry tell you they capture so
many amazed how you get around Raymond